there's been a bit of a reaction to a
lecture Brian gave which I'm a little
bit surprised that I saw the lecture it
was on BBC two so many millions of
people saw it and I thought it was
fantastic a night with the Stars that I
was amazed that he had the courage and
then the ability to explain quantum
mechanics quite like he did to to the
general public and it got quite
technical at times I didn't watch it at
the time no no but since then I've
become aware that it's all kicked off
basically
it seems to me to have caused to two
reactions one amongst the physicists
that's a more technical level and then
one amongst a group of people who have
jumped on some words that he used some
guys were posed at you know scientists
were posting their you know blogs on
blogs were saying odd you know this is
this isn't right
yeah Brian Cox himself was then
responding to these blogs it was all
kicking off on Twitter he was talking
about how everything in the universe
when you're dealing with quantum
mechanics how things are connected and
in particular he was talking about
electrons and the energy associated with
electrons and has been this sort of to
enthrone some of it quite nasty and you
know on Twitter on blogs and discussing
the rights and wrongs of what of what
Brian said he had this fantastic diamond
touch it managed to get hold of worth a
million pounds I think it was in this
diamond there are three million billion
billion carbon atoms I don't have
diamonds to play with but he had a
diamond and he said oh if I rub this
diamond then I moved the the energy
levels of the electrons within that
diamond and he said that because of
Pauli's exclusion principle that would
cause the electrons far away everywhere
in the universe to move a little bit as
well of all the electrons in the
universe must respect power Li therefore
every electron around every atom in the
universe Andy that he went on to say
that because of what's known as the
power exclusion principle which says
that no two electrons can ever be in the
same quantum state except he didn't use
the word quantum state he used the word
energy and that's where the physicists
have come in sitting precisely the same
energy level because they can't be in
the same quantum state therefore if you
move one electron up and are a group of
electrons and change their energy then
the whole system throughout the universe
will change as well it's not quite right
what he said no and but the spirit of
what you said it is okay it didn't draw
an implication in the sense of saying
anything controversial it seems to me he
do
said it's just pointing out so other
people have drawn the implications of it
they have inferred from it that that
means that for example one group of
people are saying that accounts for in
the fact that we we're all connected in
our consciousness is all connected
because when you change energy levels in
one group it immediately affects the
energy levels in another group and that
that link is real
so everything is connected to everything
else because in quantum mechanics you
can't precisely say where something is
at any given or where it is and what its
velocity is or momentum is there's an
uncertainty so you describe things in
terms of wave functions which give you
what are known is the probability of
finding things so the bigger the value
of the wave function in a given region
the more likely it is that object is
there but these wave functions can
spread and they do spread and the
interconnectedness is simply the fact
that all of the electrons the wave
function describing all of them is
spread across the universe that's what
quantum mechanics can do for you that
classical mechanics can't it can
describe all of the particles with one
wavefunction that's what the idea is and
so it's not surprising to me that if you
alter the state of an electron over here
and that it's going to have a knock-on
effect somewhere else
where all this comes from it is the
pollak screws in principle so this is
the this is the basically the idea that
no two fermions and electrons are our
fermions can occupy the same quantum
state okay now they said something
slightly different than to what Brown
said he said energy levels because you
know you could maybe associate an energy
level with one particular quantum number
but it doesn't necessarily describe the
whole quantum state of that electron
well I was a lecture I thought fantastic
lecture as I've said and I do remember
that last bit of it thinking I've never
thought about the interconnectedness of
it and they but it didn't cross my mind
that there was anything untoward that he
was he was talking about things
propagating fast in the speed of light
or anything like that he wasn't but what
has happened is first of all there's a
group of people as I said have
interpreted it as being an example of
the fact that our consciousnesses are
all connected and we're in one beautiful
Universal universe and which i think is
just irrelevant here the second group
which is more relevant is that the
physicists have picked up on the fact
that Brian was you was using the
exclusion principle that the funda of
fundamental principle in physics and
talking about in terms of energy levels
alone whereas the exclusion principle is
a bit broader than that it includes
energy levels but it includes other
unique numbers quantum numbers
associated with it with the state of
ever of a particle and so there's
there's a technical argument or
discussion that's been going on and
that's been going on a really neat level
I think watching Twitter the the
discussions that are going on so
high-quality argument as they're talking
about the various physical aspects this
isn't simple stuff but it caused the
other side of it this thing about the
consciousness etc I think so irritated
Brian I didn't see this bit of it of the
on the on the Twitter
Twitter world I don't have a Twitter
account but and it's so irritated him
that he decided he wrote an article for
The Wall Street Journal in which he
basically pointed out you know he was
not implying that that this
instantaneous effect of the of the of
the electrons reacting to one another
can be made use of in terms of sending
information you can't send any
information faster than the speed of
light so you can't make use of this to
actually say I know exactly what that
person's thinking therefore every
electron around every atom in the
universe must be shifting you know Brian
Cox I know Brian yeah it's good friend
has he staffed up has he done something
wrong no I don't think so I I think
what's happened here is the the
physicists have got very excited and and
and and and rightly started talking
about the physics that he was describing
but the the language that he used we
have to bear in mind he was using in a
television program towards the end of a
television program being broadcast to
the general public and so rather than
talking this is my interpretation I even
asked Brian rather than decided to talk
into about the quantum state which would
involve talking about the angular
momentum and the magnetic moments and
the spins it's actually you could talk
about the energy levels the angular
momentum spin there's a whole bunch of
quantum numbers that you could include
and in fact that's one of the key the
key features of this there are a number
of things that you could include to
describe this sir this particle so none
of the electrons in the universe consist
in precisely the same energy level he
decided to concentrate on the concept
that people are familiar with which is
energy the idea that you can move from
one energy level to another that was
probably knew enough for most of the
audience and so rather than describing
the things in terms of quantum states he
he concentrated on energies and said
that you couldn't have things having
exactly the same energy and that's not
necessarily the case with this power the
exclusion principle which he was making
use of you can't have two fermions
indistinguishable fermions in exactly
the same quantum state so they could
have the same energy as long as some of
the other numbers in the quantum state
are different all the electrons across
the universe instantly but imperceptibly
change their energy levels so everything
is connected to everything else I mean
there is some interconnectedness but
this is this oversimplifies and I think
that's what's got people's backs up it
said so he's talking about energy levels
there and I mean saying you can't have
two electrons in the same energy level
but that's not entirely true we know in
a helium atom two electrons occupy the
lowest energy level that the reason they
can do that the reason that doesn't
violate Pauli's exclusion principle is
because they have different angular
momentum he was picked up on that and
that then led into a more general
discussion about the implications of all
of this of the fact that you know it is
it is the case in quantum mechanics when
you you when something changes maybe the
energy of a system changes are you you
and in this case rubbing the the carbon
and you change what's known as the
Hamiltonian which effectively is the
energy of this system and that changing
in the Hamiltonian affects all the other
particles because of this property which
I mentioned that in quantum mechanics
the wave function that describes or
describes all of the particles so
changing some other in one region will
affect others in another region but it
the key thing is that doesn't break
causality it doesn't mean that you can
send a signal over to it your
experimental friend and say in the
Andromeda galaxy which they can make use
of faster than light could have traveled
that's not possible guilty of some
oversimplification I think that's why
he's on bbc2 you are on sixty symbols
yeah you know III you know personally I
think people should lay off a little bit
and it's good that you know that this is
sparking a debate within science because
at the end of it all and you know we're
all going to learn learn something right
we're all going to learn up you know ok
Brian Brian made this point it's got
people interested in what what he's
talking about and then people are
starting to look a bit deeper and get to
the real physics behind I think what he
was trying to say what he would have
liked have said but which would never
have been shown on BBC he'd said it you
you're talking as if it's all being a
very collegiate debate and everything's
been lovely but the physicists have been
a bit snobby too haven't they yeah no I
mean because they're quite passionate
about the subject but I don't think they
have necessary I mean they're now
discussing it right there the initial of
it I think that's probably a problem
with Twitter as opposed to a problem
with the physicist twitter has become
this staggeringly powerful forum by but
you're limited to what is it 140
characters or something so you can't
really describe how these exclusion
principle or what you really meant in a
lecture in that kind of language in 140
character if you can it's pretty
impressive going yeah I mean they do
it's quite normal for physicists out to
have fights with one another I think
that's how the scientific method works
so nothing wrong with that some of it's
getting a bit snotty and I think maybe
it is
little bit jealousy involved but also
you know it is important to get to get
things right I think it's actually
science working really well and it's
also a manifestation of how science
itself is evolving the way it's been
communicated there maybe some of his
responses to the Twitter comments might
have been a little bit more considered
so they say they've now actually
effectively gone underground again in
the sense of probably gone back to
original email using emails and talking
about it but the initial and discussion
about this point was done in the open
for everyone to see and it's really
interesting